هي تشكل ضغط ولا كانت ولا زالت ولا ضغطتها
قوي جدا
ومؤثره على بعض الجهاد كما ذكرت على الحزب
الديمقراطي في امريكا وعلى جهاد ثانيه في
اوروبا
وخارج اوروبا
وسوف تستمر ولكن المصالح
الاساسيه
الوطنيه
او المانيا او غيرها تاتي في المقدمه
عندما يكون هناك اختبار لهذا المصالح
ولهذا النوع من الشيعه
انا كنت في لندن مظاهرات كلها ضد البترول
يبغون العالم بدون بترول همم
البترول واحد بالاسباب في ذلك ان الحكومه
بريطانيه بدات او بدات تعود الى
مرحله اعاده التنقيب عن البترول بالذات
البترول الصخري في بريطانيا عندما اوقف
ذلك لفتره طويله وقفت مره اتحدث معهم
قلت لها يعني تكرهوا البترول قال نعم
سنقضي عليه قلت ملابس هذه من فين
سكت قلت الطاوله هذه اللي تعطن عليها
المنشوراتك وين كل هذه الاشياء البتروليه
يعني سكت ولم يستطيع الرجل